[Music]
it's the warmest jacket i've ever owned
um for the best price i've ever bought
it for
now this is the mother of all puffers
it's the orlais down jacket now this is
the one that's like the amazon
phenomenon
but the thing i'd like to point out not
only is it the warmest
but here's what i love about this jacket
it's between 150 and 199 dollars i think
different vendors have different prices
so check that out
but all the puff is in the front so you
have like a bjorn of down
but the sides are narrow thank you so
much because as somebody who struggles
with weight i'm always
weary of a puffer drew can you show them
what you're holding there on your lap
this is a brand new scarf and it's not
just any scarf it's the latest wearable
technology called the
issue scarf all right here's how it
works if you were to wear this and
someone were to take a picture of you
right the flash would reflect off of
that and you would not be visible it
would just be black look there's trevor
noah wearing it right there
i love trevor noah the stars are
obsessed with this i think nick jonas
loves it as well
right look so that's what happens you
take a picture paris hilton she's doing
it too
look at drew now look yeah see it works
does it work yeah it totally works i
can't even see your face
you know what i love a good cloak of
invisibility or a disappearing act
we've got a rossi rusty rusty take it
away yes okay so uh
you know i have a place in palm springs
it's like heaven you always feel like
you're on vacation there
and one of the things we do in palm
springs is we live our lives in caftans
and i have uh started i partnered with
this company caftco
to start ross matthews for caf cafco
caftans
and this is a brand new i'm announcing
my valentine's day caftan right now so
when you eat
too many snacks during the super bowl
this will fit you honey it's for uh
there's the first one i did that was the
palm springs inspired one that's been in
the snowstorm so you can wear them in
winter
these are for every gender every size
everybody andrew this one is for you
oh thank you roz i really get one i know
mr daniel's here to model
the um palm springs
and look everybody it's arthur and he's
here to represent the valentine's day
wednesday yes that's the valentine's day
and you can go to cafco.com
ross if you order them you'll get them
by valentine's day too but how fun is
that
and some of the crew is also sporting
that intended
oh wow there's adam our director is that
trevor or chris yes chris and trevor
look at them and there's evan and
matthew
oh everybody looks so good well go to
our website
and this will be in our little yellow
book as i said we refresh it every week
all right
um that's it for the barrymore ball it's
a beautiful piece of jewelry for a
beautiful cause the eb
healing wings butterfly diamond necklace
this is by
raven fine designers and co-designed by
someone we love here at the show
kaylee cuoco and half the proceeds go to
a cause close to kaylie's heart
the eb medical research foundation and
eb is a
painful and debilitating skin condition
and this beautiful necklace
is going to support a cure and raise
awareness
and we'll have all the information up on
our website so you can go right now
and learn more about it there and thank
you kaylee for doing that and guess what
ross
what and kaylee i bought one too oh cute
and i love it so definitely go to our
website and help support this and wear
this beautiful necklace
[Music]